hi I'm Alex and this is my recipe for
cheesecake stuffed banana bread ring
[Music]
y'all hurry know how much I like banana
bread and cheesecake this is just same
same but different so this was actually
a sequel recipe from a recipe that Alvin
had made for a cookies and cream stuffed
bundt cake bundt pans were kind of like
a thing so I wanted to play around with
a bundt pan and a new flavor I guess an
old flavor but strong flavor in a new
way so because I'm obsessed with banana
bread and cheese cake I decided to go
with banana bread and cheese cake how
original so the banana bread for this is
classic one I've used for a lot of
different videos at this point the way
we're switching it up here is the method
so
baking it in a bundt pan and filling it
with the cheesecake so of course for any
banana bread you should use ripe bananas
the darker the better this will just
make sure they had all that natural
sweetness that you want in your banana
bread never throw away your black
bananas so a tip from Lexus is that if
you have dark bananas that are getting
too dark and you don't feel like making
a banana bread at that point store them
in the freezer don't throw them away
that's banana blasphemy
so again super simple you're gonna pour
your banana bread batter into a greased
bundt pan if you don't have a bundt pan
I don't know what to tell you then you
can't do this recipe because it
specifically calls for a bundt pan I
like big bunts it again not spread that
out to make sure it's on an even layer
then you're gonna bring in your
cheesecake filling that we already made
and it was cooling spread that out
with a spatula and then for the rest of
your banana bread batter on top while
you're baking your bundt you're gonna
make the caramel which will go on top of
this bundt cake which is something you
should not skip because it really puts
this one over the edge so for the
caramel you're gonna start by cooking
down your sugar you want to make sure it
gets a golden brown and caramelized
before you add the butter in so throw in
the butter that'll melt down transfer it
off the heat and then throw in the heavy
cream once the caramel is all mixed up
it might be a little loose but once you
cool it down it will thicken right up so
while we're waiting for this cake to
bake might as well just go and subscribe
to my youtube channel so now that our
cake is all baked it's time for the fun
part
flipping it over should pop right out if
you remember to grease your bundt pan
and then you just pour your caramel
drizzle right all over that thing
so this recipe it's pretty fun because
it's like a stuffed cake ring so it's
not actually like cheesecake more as
like a cheesecake filling so it's still
like the flavor of a cheesecake topped a
meanness and sweetness you don't have to
set it like you would have to set a
cheesecake because it's just the filling
this was really really quite delicious I
have to say I've done a banana bread
bottom cheesecake I've done a banana
bread ice cream cake I do a lot of
banana things it's one of my favorites
[Music]